[Musica]
perfetto ci sono riuscita ho limato
tutti i denti aguzzi da lupo mannaro
adesso mi mancano solo le zampe forse
posso tornare ad essere normale andrò
per questo devo andare ad avvisare
vitale questo e berlino colore chi come
te l'hai visto davanti maggio devo
subito fissare vitale vitale ieri subita
qua è chiamato cosa di successo la
trasformazione sta progredendo dobbiamo
subito fare qualcosa sì una cenetta
forza una ceretta è così almeno togliamo
quelli per il momento di scherzare
dobbiamo trovare una soluzione prima che
arrivi la luna piena e vi trasformerà
completamente in un lupo mannaro
promette io non stavo scherzando però ci
si era già la ragione è meglio meglio
gira subito ho chiesto berlino cosa ne
pensa delle mie orecchie ba è un po
strano
wow sono morbidissime e anche
velocissime 6 va quindi che cosa
facciamo io ho provato una cosa ho
lavato i denti vedi qua terra di normale
in uno più i denti aguzzi da lupo
mannaro quindi forse posso provare a
tagliare le zampe tagliare le orecchie
un po pericoloso però potrei farmi un po
male
sì direi proprio di sì ma aspetta un
attimo sto pensando se tu ti trasformi
in lupo con la luna piena
perché non facciamo l'effetto contrario
cioè magari riusciamo in giardino e
quindi con l'effetto del sole forse
annulla l'effetto della luna piena
non ho mai sentito niente del genere ma
siccome non abbiamo nessun altra
possibilità possiamo provare mai chiuso
e che torniate a riguardo però
proviamoci
voi cosa ne pensate funzionerà andiamo
dai violino abbiamo giardino dai
sdraiati qua nella macaé prendi un po di
sole e di io subito no non penso che
funzionerà ma proviamo a caldissimo oggi
che brutto sentite anche voi questo
rumore vitale dov'è finito stai
mangiando come lo è quella che cos'è uno
schermo da dire non ci credo se volete
uscire fuori in giardino solo per
mangiare
no no siamo usciti fuori per per
aiutarti nella trasformazione poi già
che c'ero lo trovate le patatine poi non
del bambino a parlare a sfoggiare un po
ancora buona
[Musica]
beh questa soluzione non ha funzionato
quindi torniamo in casa sì concordo
anche perché ho finito della patatina
sanità no niente ti volevo giusto dire
una cosa che non so come dirtelo non ti
spaventare ma mi sa che la
trasformazione sta continuando
perché che cosa è successo guardati
dietro non ti spaventare però non c'è
niente che cosa è successo
guardo dietro di te proprio dietro non
ho attaccato capito mi stai prendendo in
giro senti io domando come progetto in
giro cosa che c'è qualcosa dietro di te
però guardare tutti sto prendendo in
giro
non ti sembra abbastanza che ho le
orecchie del tempo puoi anche prendermi
in giro portate stessa allora questo che
cos'è
hai visto che non ti stavo prendendo in
giro
[Musica]
eh già devo devo andare a vedere le
ruspe che
sì quello che hanno pure la cosa la
prossima cosa cosa farà allora i baffi
mamma non si può togliere
credo di no e allora cosa facciamo
ho un'idea berlino è un cane quindi
forse lui potrebbe scappare la soluzione
proviamo a chiedere a lui perché tu
discende dai lupi vero puoi dirmi qual è
la soluzione per non trasformarsi in
lupo mannaro aiutano il merlino che cosa
devo fare per interrompere la
trasformazione non so se merlino ha
capito guarda merlino né di queste zampe
vogliono dire che mi sto trasformando in
un lupo mannaro che queste orecchie
guarda non si mangiano e questa una coda
devo sbrigarmi capisci cosa potrei fare
per interrompere la trasformazione
cantando ti dà forse devo seguirlo
andiamo a berlino dimmi dove devo andare
per trovare una soluzione
quindi devo aprire questa porta
ok aspetta che l'altro
ho capito devo salire questo provero no
quindi dobbiamo indicato guarda sta
portando la sopra sopra le scale a
chiocciola nel soffitto
vi ricordate cosa c'è nella soffitta
mi sa che devo per forza tornare là
sopra e forse li troverà una soluzione
in genere berlino non si sbaglia mai
quindi forse la soprattutto non la
soluzione perde trasformarmi e tornare
normale e diamo anche sbrigarvi però lui
non si sbaglia mai ma se ti succede
qualcosa che cosa faccio io non so se
sia una buona idea che tu venga con me
perché potresti essere morso anche due
se diventiamo entrambi di banari non
riusciremo mai a salvarsi quindi devo
andare io da solo ok tu rimani qui ad
ascoltare ok ma per ios ma con cui
puntanto vari sbrigati sbrigati vediamo
fra focus lasciato mi piace per portarmi
fortuna
[Musica]
io
stavo uscendo dalla camera riesco a
capirlo ma cosa starà succedendo la sua
sento dei rumori strani
[Musica]